but now urgent news after a serious
and prolonged illness at the age of 90,
mikhail gorbachev died the
first and only president of the
soviet union
we give the dismantling of the
infrastructure of fear that dominated the world such inertia
that it will be difficult to
stop
[music]
Gorbachev's
potential
was struggling with the
bible
invalid file
station
.
[music]
more efficiency more democracy
more organization and discipline and
then we will be able to bring perestroika into full swing
give new impetus to
developing socialism
[music]
be aiko significance in despair of sun
has a built-in just drink of the century ftp
[music]
in force  the current
situation with the formation of the Commonwealth of
Independent States,
I cease my activities as
President of the USSR